change lives change organizations
diabetes organizations change the world
part of the reason why we all came to
Stanford was because we had a dream a
lot of our dreams are on a world scale
it's no longer one can't really other I
think you just working in the world it's
gonna become very important for you to
know different cultures languages the
way to do business
I'm really interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation and
energy clean tech space we work and
interest in improve private investor the
pressure pockets healthcare is really
one of the places where you can really
change lives and change the world what I
want to do for the rest of my life these
problems of you know world hunger of
major education gaps they can be solved
I have had several opportunities my
South Africa service learning trip the
focus was education it was so powerful
to see that in spite of the constrained
resources how people are making such a
huge impact when you have very difficult
operating environments where the
economy's difficult when it's challenged
and I you have the best opportunity to
change the organization's to change the
people's lives and basically hopefully
change the world change the world
change the world dunya initiative change
the world I've been hearing about China
a lot and traditionally India and China
have been rivals so I wanted to be on
the ground and understand that because
as part of Asia China is an opening
market and if we can develop some good
ties it would be really awesome no
matter how much we talk about countries
all over here and we see how much China
has it fast we see the potential of the
small
these experiences definitely had an
impact with my interested in clean tech
to go to the steel plant and see all of
the coal piles that get burned every day
and breathe in the air my plan is to
venture into clean tech as soon as
possible doing a Google steady trip we
met a lot of companies and I think for
me the biggest takeaway was provided
transformational products that are good
that is going to improve people's
lifestyle and also give them access I
think that we not often have a very
clear idea of what's going on on the
ground with respect to this this service
learning trip the social innovation
Fellows Program the loan forgiveness
program are perfect examples of the kind
of ways that the GSB seeks to inspire
students and help them look for
solutions to make a world a better place
and I want to make environmental
improvements globally either private
equity or venture capital I want to
start a company and garner focus though
in the healthcare industry either
internal strategy or for management
consulting is something the general
manager in healthcare I can do whatever
I put my my team we have a group of
alumni who have had incredible impact in
the world in a wide variety of different
spheres been Phil Knight the founder of
Nike Chuck Schwab who founded the
concept of discount brokerage injecting
Novogratz through the acumen fund is
funding Mason organizations in the
developing world these are individuals
who who have lived on mantra they have
changed the world
if the GSP hadn't prepared me it really
wouldn't be possible for me to be here
at this age at this level
the global focus the student body being
diverse the global acquirement it was
all set Stanford apartment Stanford
Graduate School Business is a place
where people will believe in your dreams
and believe in you almost before you do
yourself and gives you the confidence to
know that you can impact the world in a
positive way the cornerstone of our new
campus reads dedicated to the things
that haven't happened yet and the people
who will bring them up
and I think that in a nutshell captures
the essence of the GSB